let's bring in our next guest retired
u.s army brigadier general don baldock
um
let's just um
flip to the second part of of that
question we don't quite have time for
the for to follow up there which was if
the the worst happens and as the
intelligence is being leaked you know
there's a full-on invasion you know what
should we do
well steve thank you and my best to your
viewers and
of course we're in a
a hugely difficult situation right now
and it'll be even more difficult when
if and when
putin decides to invade either
a limited invasion or a full-scale
invasion and so
we have no diplomacy we have no
deterrents that that they've implemented
at all
you mentioned peace through strength and
the earlier conversation we haven't even
arrayed our forces our strategic forces
uh in the right areas to be able to to
do this nobody wants to send ground
troops into the ukraine but we have so
many other
assets that we could use
to respond ahead of time to prevent
putin from doing anything but he's
playing a chess game and we're playing a
checkers game and we have such an
imbalance in our national security right
now uh between the homeland and and
foreign policy that i think that we need
to get ready for the worse and yes
is biden ready to uh respond to that no
and putin knows that and that's the
difference between a chess game and a
checker game
yeah yes um what about the i'd like to
ask you what you had in mind with those
other resources that you said that could
be deployed short of ground troops i
think everyone's in agreement we don't
want to see that at all what what should
have been done
well i think that we should have had our
united states navy in there uh we have a
superb navy a strategic navy that's
second to none
surface subsurface air
he's got his and the black sea and in
the mediterranean we should have doubled
down on that we should have layered our
own naval forces in there our strategic
air force
we also have a number of indirect assets
the other thing that we're doing is
we're pulling out our tactical assets on
the ground special forces now i've been
retired for four years but i've served
with these guys i've led these guys i
know what they can do when it comes to
stay behind operations in case of an
invasion i know what they can do to
prepare the civilian defense forces and
i know what i know what they can do to
advise assist
uh a company uh train and equip the
ukrainian forces to take the fight even
more lethal
to to russia the ukrainians are going to
fight they're brave they will fight
they're not like
afghanistan or any other place that we
have been in they will hold the line we
need to back them up and we're just not
there to back them up because like i
said we're playing a checkers game
they're playing a chess game we're not
matt we're over matched in the policy
and strategy area here and they know it
well let's talk about that because the
one thing that's really struck me from
the beginning of this whole crisis as
as we've seen it unfold is this way in
which we we've seen extraordinarily
detailed intelligence leaked people are
so skeptical and suspicious about all of
this given the history of the past kind
of um in the in the recent past and it
seems to me like they the biden you know
people they think this is on a new like
i said a new type of warfare they and in
fact in this new york times piece today
they're saying they're very proud of it
they think you know putin plays this
game with information and so on and now
they're they're playing the putin's game
and they're going to beat him i think
it's tremendously risky because actually
you're dealing with a very unpredictable
character and by constantly putting
things out into the public domain it
might actually provoke putin what do you
make of it
well i i agree with you and first of all
putin respects strength
and the congresswoman had it perfect
they weren't going to mess with
president trump and and that's a fact
i you know i was serving as a general
officer they messed with they messed
with uh the obama administration and now
they're messing with the biden
administration they have no respect for
our national security team writ large
whether it's the leadership and
department of defense sec department of
state or the national security team they
look at afghanistan i mean exactly i
mean we embolden china russia north
korea and iran
uh to such an extent that
they are they are not even worried about
you know what we're going to do and this
characterizing this as anything but
putin putin
massing his troops under his most
qualified general under his most
ruthless general
to do
a cross-border invasion and not look at
it in those terms is a huge mistake and
and to play games like you're you're you
know you're
you're you know more clever than the
other guy this is straight up blocking
and tackling there's nothing complicated
about it and they're weak they're
they're they're ineffective leaders and
that's what he that's how he's going to
beat us
well there you are i mean i'm afraid
that that all sounds all too true but
general baldwick as always
great to have you with us tonight we
really appreciate it hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else